welcome to the presentation on ratios
now i'm going to start just giving you a
definition of ratios and this i got from
wikipedia a ratio is a quantity that
denotes the proportional amount of
magnitude of one quantity relative to
another so i'm going to tell you from
the beginning that i think a ratio is
something that's easier to understand
than to give a definition for because i
don't think that wikipedia definition is
that useful let me give you some
examples
if there are
let's say there are
let me get make sure this pen size is
right
let's say there are 10
boys
and two girls
in a class
so the ratio
of boys to girls would be 10 to 2
or
10 to 2 those are two different ways of
writing it and we know from fractions
that that's also the same thing as
to 1
or
over one we want to keep the one there
because we know that it's a ratio of one
thing to another thing so what does that
mean all that means is that for every
five boys there's one girl
and so if we told you that the ratio of
boys to girls in a room is five to one
and we told you that there are
let's say we told you that there are
100 girls
then we'd know that well for every one
of those girls there's five boys so that
means that there would be 500 boys
right
or you could also look at that as the
ratio of boys to girls is 500
to 100
which equals 5 to one
and this is a typical way that a ratio
is written 500 to 100 of boys to girls
now let me ask a couple questions
based on that i think you get the
general idea
if i told you that the ratio of
let's say
red
balls
to
green balls
in a bag
is
let's say it's two to three
and then if i also told you that there
are
let's say they're
there
are let's say
red balls
how many uh blue balls how many green
balls are there well what we say is the
ratio of red balls to green ball so we
know that there are 40 red balls
and then we want to solve for the number
of green balls
that that is equal to
two to three
and then we could just solve this we
mult we just cross multiply forty times
three
is a hundred and twenty
is equal to
two g
and then we just solve we just say g
equals 60.
and there's an easier way of of doing
this kind of in your head and this is
the algebraic way that will always work
but you could also just say let me write
this a little bit this is a 3 down here
you can also say well to get from 2 to
40 i had to you have to multiply
by 20.
so to get from 3 to g i'm also going to
multiply by 20
and so 3 times 20 is 60. that's another
way to do it a lot of you might actually
find it more intuitive just to think
about it well if for every two
red balls there are three green balls
then if there are 40
red balls
then it makes sense that there would be
60 green balls because for every
for every 20 there would be 30 for every
40 there would be 60. i hope i'm not
completely confusing you
let me give you another example let's
say the ratio
of boys
to girls
is equal to
um
two
two to seven
and if i were to tell you that the total
class
the class
has 180 kids in it
can we figure out how many boys and
girls there are in the class
well let's think about it
well we know that the
boys
to girls
is equal to
two to seven
and we also know that the boys plus
girls
is equal to
180.
so here we have a system of two
equations and two unknowns and you could
actually if you really think about you
could actually solve this without
algebra but i'll show you the algebraic
way because when com problems get
complicated this will always work
so we can do is we can do substitution
we know that
b
is equal to
over 7 g
right i just multiplied both sides of
this equation by g
times g cancels out there and then times
g and you get this
and then we can just substitute that
back in for b
so then we have 2 over 7
g
plus g
is equal to
180.
and what's 2 7 g
plus we could say 1g or 7 over 7 g
well you could do the fraction but it's
2 7 plus 1 is the same thing as
that's equal to
two
sevenths plus seven sevenths right
because that's just one
g is equal to one eighty
and i'm jumping around on the chalkboard
on purpose to to intentionally confuse
you
so let me uh okay this is where i am so
2 7 plus 7 7 is g equals 180. so we have
9 7
g is equal to 180
and we just multiply both sides times
the reciprocal
times 7 over 9.
oops that's not a g that's a 9.
once again intentional device to confuse
you these cancel out and you get g
equals 180
g
equals
times seven
over nine well one eighty divided by
nine this is just twenty
right
so g is equal to one hundred forty and
so if there are 140 girls in the room
how many boys are there going to be well
we know that the whole class is 180
people so there's and we know b plus g
is 180 so there's going to be the boys
are equal to
40.
and and this is really um you know about
about as difficult as i guess we could
say basic ratio problems get
there's nothing really difficult about
ratios they're just representing for
every amount of one thing how much do
you have of the other thing and then you
can use that i guess ratio
to if you have some other information in
terms of how many total people there are
or how many total objects there are or
how much of one object there is you can
use that to figure out how much of the
other object there is or how many total
objects there are um i think you're
you're now ready to try some of the
ratio problems and i'm going to do
another presentation on what i would
consider slightly more advanced ratio
problems so have fun